kids in their honesty you gotta love it
Kate Middleton spilling on how her son
nine-year-old Prince George reacts to
seeing old photos of her and his dad
Prince William
mostly this image which has been
plastered all over memorabilia since
their engagement in 2010.
it all unfolded on Tuesday in Wells
where the newly minced princess of Wells
shares a story with a royalist waving a
flag featuring The now Infamous Pig
William and Kate are very Hands-On
parents I think that's all part of
wanting to give the the children
particularly this ordinary family
upbringing that is just so normal
certainly by Royal standards from the
looks of it Kate and William are making
good on keeping things normal because
sharing opinions on Old picks isn't the
only time the mountbatten wins her
kiddos speak their minds especially
seven-year-old Charlotte who was never
shy to correct her older brother in the
classiest way like this moment when she
reminded her big bro to bow at the
Queen's funeral
foreign
's Platinum Jubilee Charlotte corrected
George's posture after he made the
mistake of resting his hand on the
balcony
[Music]
Charlotte clearly a natural-born leader
Charlotte is a very happy little girl a
very confident little girl she loves to
perform
um and she's a big personality we're
guessing she gets some of that gutsy
energy from her mama who took extra time
to talk with the people of Wells on her
first official visit to the country
since being named its princess
like Kate said Wells is a special place
for her and William they live there as
newlyweds after their 2011 nuptials
including after the birth of Prince
George this trip also marks the end of
the official Royal morning period
following the death of Queen Elizabeth
II
[Music]